Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode Live
at the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host, Rawkode.
Thank you for joining us today. Today, we
are taking a look at jsPolicy,
faster and easier policies for Kubernetes using TypeScript
and JavaScript.
If you like rating everything as code, today
is a great episode for you.
Before we begin, there's a little bit of
housekeeping. Please remember to subscribe to the channel
and tick the bell to get notifications of
all new episodes. And I would also really
appreciate it if you could like the video
and comment and share with all of your
technologist friends.
You can also support the Academy with the
various membership options available. You can find them
at rockload.live.
There is Sandbox, incubation, and graduated, a level
for individuals and organizations.
And if you wanna come and chat with
nearly 600 technologists on cloud native Kubernetes and
everything in between, join us in the Discord
available at Rawkode.chat.
Alright. Let's introduce today's wonderful guest. I am
joined once again by Rich and Lucas from
the Loft team. Hey there. How are you
both doing?
Really good. It's good to be on again,
David.
I always feel really bad when I throw
that question out to two people, and I
just let them decide who's gonna go first.
And I really should just
I I should be better than this. I
should say, hey, Rich. Hey, Lucas. How's it
going? Or maybe that doesn't really help. I'll
work on it.
Okay. So for anyone who doesn't remember you
from last name, as unfamiliar reviews from Twitter,
etcetera, can we just get some introductions? And
we'll start with you, Rich, just because you're
on the left, and then feel free to
hand that over to Lucas.
Yeah.
My name is Rich Burrows. I'm a senior
developer advocate at Loft Labs.
I've been with the company for about six
months right now. We work a lot on
making Kubernetes
easier for developers to use and also
people like platform engineers who own the clusters
and are managing them. So we are very
interested in multitenancy,
self-service,
all of those kinds of things. We really
are looking to find the areas that that
people are kind of bumping their shins on
and try to make them easier.
Thank you for sharing. Lucas?
Yeah. I'm Lucas, CEO
of Loft Labs. I have the pleasure of
working with Rich on all of these exciting
topics. And,
yeah, we're really on a mission to,
you know, help companies
roll out Kubernetes and expand their use from
you know, essentially, right now, they may have,
you know, 10 or 20 or even 40
people having access to Kubernetes, and we help
them to do, you know, essentially the leap
to a thousand or even 5,000 engineers or
more.
And, obviously, there's a lot of tooling and
automation required. And jsPolicy,
which we're talking about today, is, you know,
one of the projects that we're working on
in the open source space
that may make that transition a little easier.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing.
For people that aren't familiar or don't remember,
we had you on recently, and we took
a look at vCluster.
So you're kinda tackling a lot of these
really difficult problems that people have with Kubernetes.
The first one with multitenancy,
and we had an absolutely flawless demo. So
you have set the bar high, I'm afraid.
And we're we're not gonna accept anything less
today.
And now jsPolicy,
which is tackling that really difficult thing where
people are wanting to write more admission controllers
and policies to restrict the segment access to
their Kubernetes clusters as well. So
I'm I'm curious about the what's the what's
the drive there? Like, I mean, these are
really difficult problems. Are you just sitting down
and going, right, what's painful for us and
let's solve it for other people? Or do
you you got some other semantic videos in
there?
Yeah. I think it's it's pretty much customer
driven. Right? We're in a lot of conversations
with these platform teams that essentially run into
these problems
that have to manage Kubernetes at scale for
a large number of engineers.
And, you know, in these conversations, we just
spot challenges.
And, yeah, I I mean, there are definitely
pretty hard problems. And with the technologies that
we're building, we're trying to make it as
easy as possible
for these platform team teams to essentially, you
know, enable developers to more efficiently work with
Kubernetes. And, yeah, they are complicated. So big
shout out to, you know, LoftLab's CTO,
Fabian,
who is actually grinding a lot of the
code on this end. You know? We may
come up with feature ideas and throw them
at at Fabian, but he's actually the brain
of, you know, how do we actually implement
this and, you know, make it work at
scale. So big shout out to him.
Yeah. He's fantastic. We've also had some new
engineering hires recently too, so the team is
growing.
Awesome.
Maybe we can kind of address jsPolicy
directly then.
I mean, do you wanna give the the
the pitch first? Like, what is j what
is jsPolicy,
and why should people take note?
Who wants to tackle that? Yeah. I'm Indian.
Yeah. There we go.
Yeah. The other behind jsPolicy is essentially
writing policies
as code.
And I think the the pain point that
we saw
was essentially that OPA with
Rigo
has a language. You know, it's kind of
like the default
standard when you're looking at dynamic admission control
in Kubernetes. Everybody looks at Policy Agent,
and they have to adopt Regal
as their policy language,
which is not a, you know, Turing complete
programming language and feels,
you know, very off for a lot of
engineers.
And, you know, we are thinking, can't we
simplify that by essentially just taking a language
that people know,
you know, but still assure that when people
write these policies that they can maintain them
very well, that they can test them very
well, and that it's very integrated into what's
what's already existing in terms of ecosystem.
And JavaScript and TypeScript just have such a
vibrant ecosystem when you're looking at, you know,
testing frameworks
and CICD integration, all these kind of things.
Right? It's pretty seamless because, you know, it's
it's just such a popular language and such
a, you know, vibrant ecosystem.
So, yeah, we tried JavaScript,
and that seems to, you know, reduce the
complexity
a lot in terms of you know, if
I write a a policy in Rigo and
I look like three months later, I look
at that policy. Right? I'm having a pretty
hard time understanding of what it actually does.
And, I may be the person who actually
wrote that policy. Right? So I don't wanna
know how anybody else feels that has no
clue about this policy in the first place.
And we hope to make that a little
bit easier with JavaScript, especially since most companies
already have people that know JavaScript. Although they
may, you know, not necessarily be part of
the platform team, they may actually be working
on some front end stuff,
but they are definitely qualified engineers
in pretty much any company that know JavaScript.
Yeah. I'd I'd add a couple of things.
You know? First first, you don't have to
be a JavaScript expert to, you know, write
some basic policies with the tool. You don't
have to go the TypeScript route. You know?
We'll we'll kinda show you the basics too.
But,
you know, the thing I like about it
is that
it shouldn't have to be the platform engineers
who write all the policies, in my opinion.
You know, there are some policies that you
wanna be maybe cluster wide and and and
have those folks writing, but I feel like
other people, you know, potentially should be able
to contribute too. And and, you know, you
you could have platform teams I mean, application
engineer teams, you know, writing policies
or at least being able to read them
and understand them. Right? So so, like, even
if they're not the ones writing them, they
can at least look at the policies and
and kinda know what's going on.
Yeah. That makes a lot of sense. I
mean, JavaScript
I mean, this has to be the biggest
programming language in the world these days, I
think, with just the ecosystem is there. And
it doesn't matter if your background is from
the front end world or JavaScript world anyway
because it's a c derivative language. Like, it
feels familiar even if you've never read a
line of JavaScript before to go developers, to
c developers, c plus plus developers, even Java
developers to a certain degree. Like, the language
primitives and constructs are are mostly familiar. So
I think it's a really sensible choice for
a tool like this. And to go back
to Lukasys point, like, I mean, we've all
been the person that looks at a bit
of of code Regal or not Regal, but
then goes, the hell is this code doing?
Who what idea wrote this? And then you
run the git log or whatever the git
show, and you go, oh, it was it
was me. I've certainly been guilty of that
many, many times. So I think it's it's
nice that I will have the potential and
ability to write
policies in JavaScript because,
hopefully, it solves that burden and that just
that cognitive load that it takes to read
and consume, even YAML at times. So very
excited for today's session.
Yeah. When when Lucas first told me about
the project and and showed me what they
were working on, kind of the prototype,
I I was immediately
struck by how easy it was to just
read the example policies and understand what's going
on. And and I'm not somebody who writes
a lot of JavaScript. You know? So it's
it's not like I I have more than
a very, you know, very, very fundamental understanding
of it. But you'll you'll see as we
get into this that, like, it's pretty easy
to tell what's going on. Uh-huh. I'm I'm
I'm worried now, Rich. You said easy twice,
and I'm like, oh, like, that's that is
I shouldn't have said that for a demo.
Then when something goes wrong, I'm gonna go,
you said it was easy, and then Hulk
smashed my computer. So
okay.
Let's pull up the homepage
because I think, you know, and I'll I'll
put some words in the viewer's mouth here.
It's like, we've already mentioned Regal and Opa,
and we've got Qyvernal that people are familiar
with and we've had episodes on in the
past. And there is this kind of comparison
here. Do you maybe wanna run through this
and just tell people what is different in
jsPolicy versus these other systems?
Yeah. I mean, obviously, the the the biggest
different differentiator is how you define these policies.
In Kavana, it's it's mostly YAML,
very, very close to Kubernetes.
I mean, in the end, you know, jsPolicy
and and OPAL also have their CRDs.
Right? But the actual policy logic is not
defined in in in YAML itself.
All of them support validating policies, of course.
There are some differences regarding
mutating policies.
You have a especially when you look at
Kibana,
that is pretty challenging to express
changing an object in YAML, right, just because
of the limitation of that declarative language
versus,
you know, in in JS policy,
essentially, it's it's mutating an object just as
you would do in any, you know, kind
of object oriented language. Right? You have this
JSON object. And and, I mean, it's kind
of funny. You know, Kubernetes,
essentially, we're writing YAML code, but kubectl under
the hood converts everything to JSON, right, and
before it sends to the API server.
So what better language to,
you know, manipulate these objects with than JavaScript?
I mean, it's literally the JavaScript object notation.
And so
it's pretty straightforward to essentially,
you know, have something like pod dot spec
dot something, you know,
and then essentially write equals new value. Right?
It's pretty straightforward.
And I think one thing that is really,
really different about jsPolicy is
a new type of policy, actually.
We introduced a policy that is reactive,
and we call them controller policies
because they're kinda similar to actually writing a
fully fledged Kubernetes controller.
So, essentially, there are a couple of things
that you cannot do with policies. So let's
say you
wanna have a network policy in each newly
created namespace. Right?
That could be a policy in your company.
How do you enforce
that this network policy is there? Right?
That is really hard in admission control
because
in the regular admission control flow,
that is part of the namespace creation request.
Right? If I run kubectl create namespace,
the admission control happens first before the namespace
object is actually persisted in etcd.
But the the network policy can only be
created after
the namespace exists because it has to live
in that namespace.
It's pretty challenging. So what we do with
controller policies is essentially introducing a new class
of policies
or that essentially lets you react to Kubernetes
events.
So we have the event in Kubernetes that
is, you know, thrown. Namespace has been created.
Right? And you can watch on that event
and then essentially react to that,
You know, whether you check if a network
policy has been applied within five minutes or
so
or if you, you know, created
yourself throughout that controller policy, there's, you know,
just so many options.
And then another big difference is essentially
JS policy is based on JavaScript. So you
can make use of the entire,
like, tool chain regarding testing frameworks,
regarding package management. Right? You can essentially there's
NPM. Js,
the registry for NPM packages.
You can essentially use any JavaScript or TypeScript
library out there and just import that
and use it in your JavaScript policy.
And we see that as a huge benefit
to essentially share policy code
because right now, you know,
you have to create something like a policy
hub or something like that
to essentially share policies, like a totally different
ecosystem,
and it's a lot of work to build
that up and to maintain that.
But if we're already having NPM. Js, you
know, that's essentially a given. It's pretty straightforward
for people to run NPM publish and even
publish things to their own internal registry
and, you know, share things across teams and
things like that.
You don't need to reinvent the wheel, and
that's a pretty interesting concept.
Yeah. Most companies are gonna already have that
internal registry too. You know? So
Yeah. I'm I'm sold. Like, you know, the
package management and been haven't been able to
distribute my policies via NPM and pull them
in that way, think, is is super cool
just because I'm familiar enough with that tooling.
And, you know, I think anyone who's written
any kind of open policies, testing them is
really hard and been able to fall back
on pretty mature testing frameworks available in the
kind of node and JavaScript ecosystem, I think
is an absolute bonus.
And I'm
really excited about controller policies. And I want
to see if maybe we could play around
a little bit with that today.
You know, mutating admission controllers are great for
modifying the the YAML that's kind of being
admitted, but being able to actually
react to that and deploy more or other
things, I think, is really cool too.
So this is gonna be fun.
Now you pointed this out to me just
before we went live. So I figured we
could run through a couple of these just
to show people what the JS policy looks
like, what it's actually doing, how it can
how just how it works as a high
level overview. And then what we'll do is
we'll dive over to my cluster and get
all of this running.
So this is like your JS policy playground
in a sense and that we have access
to
a policy here
and a standard Kubernetes object here, and we
have a traffic light system to tell us
what is happening.
Did I mess that up? Yeah. Really right.
No. That's totally right.
I really like starting with this deny default
namespace one too because I feel like it's
something that everybody's gonna understand,
right, even people without a lot of Kubernetes
experience that, you know, we just don't want
things to to get launched into that namespace.
Okay. So
let's just run through this this policy then.
We've got our API version in kind, which
I'm sure you're all familiar with. We've got
access to policy.jspolicy.com.
I have not seen v one beta one
in a while. That's a nice flashback. I'm
glad to see that still kicking. And then
we've got Kang JS policy. We've got metadata.
And then here's the guts of it.
So we have to tell it which operations
that we want to apply the policy to,
which resources.
We've got the scope. So I guess names
based and cluster wide would be my two
options here.
And then we've got a JavaScript key
that just has a conditional
in it.
I mean, I can just look at that,
and I I understand
what's going on, which I think is a
pretty Exactly. No. Yeah.
Like I said, when I first when I
first started looking at this, I was just
almost shocked at how easy it was to,
like, look at these things and understand them
even as somebody who's not written really much
JavaScript at all.
Yeah. So we're we've got a policy here
that says whenever I create a resource, any
resource, as designated by the star,
as the request object's namespace is default, we
just deny it. I'm assuming deny is just
a a special function that blocks the the
admission of the the object.
So
let's take a look. We got this ability
here
to then create
an object.
This is in the default namespace,
and we get a deny. Nice and simple.
So I guess the fix here
is to change the namespace
and it works.
That's cool. I think it's a nice visual
way to introduce people to the project and
just understand what's actually happening. Although, I suspect
at some point in my career, I'm gonna
start dropping actual real policies and payload and
workloads into this than just using it as
a sanity check. But we've
got people in the chat already asking if
they can use us to break clusters on
clustered. Thanks,
Russell. They're always thinking ahead of me.
We got a question from a mad hand
as well in the chat asking, is this
similar to Pulumi?
Wondering if want to tackle maybe the differences
here.
I I guess could be seen like that.
Oh, sorry, Rich. Go ahead. Oh, I was
just gonna say, I don't I don't know
that Pulumi has
functions for for
doing policy stuff, but I could be wrong.
Not to my knowledge. I guess, like, I
I think Lucas was about to say that
it's it's maybe a bit similar in that,
you know, you're able to use a language
that is a standard language that you're already
familiar with, you know, to to do the
things that you wanna do as opposed to,
like, having to, like, learn a a new
language or a DSL or something like that.
Yeah. I mean, from what I can see
here, I'll just add my kind of perspective
to it. You know, I I would probably
use Pulumi to apply these policies
to my cluster and then use JS policy
within the cluster to be the controller and
the admission
aspect of it. So I think they work
side by side together pretty well.
Yeah. The scope of Pulumi is a lot
bigger.
Yeah. That's true.
Alright. Let's take a look at this, this
add node selector. So this is a mutating
policy.
So this just means that
when we apply something to the cluster, we
can use jsPolicy to augment it or make
it conform to whatever policies
we have.
Is that I've never had to describe mutating
the mission controls before. Does that does that
make sense?
I think so. Yeah. So the same yeah.
Fixing resources, right, to make them match the
policy is is a good description.
Cool. Yeah. I think an, you know, an
example
that people would probably be familiar with is,
you know, making sure that things have labels
on them. You know?
Yeah.
Cool. Well, what I love right. First and
foremost, right, it's not even the fact that
this is a mutating policy, right, is that
I have comments that live within the multilayer
YAML that are gonna persist if I do
a get or describe on this YAML. Right?
They're not gonna disappear on me, which is
something that happens with the control plane. When
I apply YAML with comments, they're all stripped
out.
So I really like that
assuming it works the way I think it
does.
But what this admission controller is doing is
we've got create again. This time, we're only
mutating pods.
And
if it has
a label
called add node selector true,
it sets Yeah. It's like Okay. So it's
adding the the namespaces,
right, that have this
label.
So the namespace has that label then. But,
again, like, in this demo, we don't have
a real cluster, so it won't really check
the the namespace has that label.
Oh, right. Okay. So the namespace selector says,
if the namespace itself has a label called
node add selector true,
then what our policy is doing here is
saying, okay, add a node selector
through value test test two and then mutate
the object. So it's just adding a node
selector to the
YAML. So
there we go.
Adds these fields here.
I like it. Nice and simple.
Here's
a question then that comes into mind. So
far what we've seen in these examples is
that we use this JavaScript key.
Does that change the TypeScript for TypeScript or
is it just a generic key and I
could put TypeScript in here if I want?
Like
Yeah. That's kind of diving a little bit
more into,
you know, the architecture of JS policy.
Essentially,
there are there are three different
CRDs
that we're introducing.
There's the jsPolicyCRD
that you're seeing here,
and then there's the jsPolicyBundleCRD.
You know, folks that may be familiar with
JavaScript know about these, like, Webpack bundles and
things like that. It's essentially compressing JavaScript to,
you know, embedding all the dependencies and making
it highly efficient, essentially optimizing the code.
And the same thing happens when you
take TypeScript and you compile it down to,
like, vanilla JavaScript. Right? Because that's essentially what's
running in your browser later on.
And, you know, you there's two ways of
creating a policy. You can either embed the
JavaScript logic like it is here
and write it in line in the, you
know, spec JavaScript.
But you can also create that JS policy
bundle
and leave this spec JavaScript out, and then
JS policy would take that bundle.
If you do the inline route like we
do here, what actually happens behind the scenes
is when you're creating a JS policy object
like shown here
and the controller sees that spec JavaScript object,
it actually runs Webpack
and creates that bundle for you.
So in the end, what what the you
know, we're using v eight. That's like Google's
JavaScript
execution engine that they run-in Chrome, etcetera,
And we actually let it run only the
Javis the JS policy bundle.
But how that's created is essentially up to
the user. It can be, you know, created
out of your type TypeScript project with a
custom,
you know, CICD pipeline or whatever that creates
a bundle object and then the JS policy,
or you do it in line and then,
essentially,
the controller would would do that translation for
you.
Alright. Very cool.
Okay. My next question.
Does it support Wasm bundles?
No. Not at this point. It's actually a
pretty pretty interesting
route to go. I think, you know, Cube
Warden from the Rancher folks is pretty much
focused on that. It's kinda funny. We were
pretty much working at the same time on
jsPolicy when they were starting to work on.
And we had a little chat before KubeCon
Europe when they announced it, And it was
super interesting for you know, to hear
that they essentially had the same idea at
the same time but went a different route
because they're like they went the WASM route,
and we went, like, the v eight, you
know,
plain JavaScript route.
Yeah. Cool. Yeah. I
think it just shows that there is a
demand and a need that people want to
be able to write their policies and languages
that they understand and have the ability to
do conditionals and loops and all these other
things that we need. So,
yeah. Definitely.
Okay. You mentioned the architecture.
We do have the architecture on the docs
page if I remember.
Is this the one?
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. You can kinda see with these
little red bubbles
of what the execution
order essentially is.
You know, when the when the kubectl request
comes in at the Kubernetes API server,
It's essentially calling
the webhook manager inside JS policy,
and that webhook manager really looks at the
JS policy objects, which you see here in
green. The the three green
areas are essentially the CRDs that we're introducing,
the jsPolicy,
jsPolicyBundle,
and then jsPolicyViolations,
which essentially is, you know, more for reporting
purpose to see, you know, what went wrong
inside the cluster, which policies
were actually hit and denied and requests and
things like that.
And then jsPolicy,
those objects essentially define,
you know, which objects to target. So they
tell the webhook manager, hey. Whenever we're creating,
as we saw earlier, pods or and, you
know,
things with certain
labels that match,
you know,
those kind of things are defined in that
jsPolicy resource. Also, operations that create, delete, you
know,
whatever is sent to the Kubernetes API server.
And then that webhook manager essentially would call
mutating, validating
webhooks as part of the regular, you know,
Kubernetes,
you know, API server request workflow.
And it's essentially, you know, mutating
webhooks executed
sequentially
because otherwise, you kind of have, like, you
know, who wins both,
right, the object. Right? Both mutated.
So they executed
sequentially just like Kubernetes does it.
And then validating is executed
in parallel because, you know, if one of
them tells you deny, it's automatically denied. So
we can speed things up by running them
in parallel. Kubernetes does these web calls under
the hood, essentially.
And then objects are persisted in c r
d in in etcd,
which is step number three here. And then
there's the part that typically admission control frameworks
don't address because it's outside of the scope
of regular admission control workflow,
and that's these events that are created from
the API server
when new resources,
you know, are added to etcd or altered
or anything happens inside the Kubernetes cluster.
And that's essentially when these controller policies would
be executed.
Okay. So
we'll we'll get hands on in just a
second, but I've got one question because I
wanna make sure I understood this little bit
correctly.
So jsPolicy when running my cluster is
registered as a dynamic admission controller like these
other tools, and that handles
the mutating and validating aspect.
But you're actually setting is it just like
a a global watch on the Kubernetes API
server that says give me all changes and
it goes through the controller policies?
I think we're watching on events here.
Okay. So it's just the Since
yeah.
Alright. Okay. Let's is there anything else in
the documentation you would like to go over
before we deploy this to our cluster?
No. Let's get some hands on experience with
it. Sounds good. Awesome.
So should I do quick start or the
fill guide install? You got a preference?
No. Let's do quick start. That that's probably
the easiest one to get started with.
Okay. So it wants me to use helm
to deploy to my cluster.
I think I have helm.
I do. Okay.
So we just do a standard install, create
namespace,
off we go.
If they want it long.
Done.
So let's see what we've got installed on
our
cluster.
And I'm assuming I created just by that
create namespace that we have a jsPolicy
namespace. Okay.
Let's take a look.
Pods.
So it's just a single pod. This is
the one that's running the v runtime
and the I'm assuming, like, an HTTP server
to receive the
the the Webex from the API server.
Right. You can also run this in essentially
more high available mode. Right? Essentially, spin up
more replicas and things like that. That is
also possible.
Alright. Nice.
Okay.
So
validating.
We have a jsPolicy validating when I put
good mesh controller, and I'm assuming the exact
same on the mutating side.
No.
Interesting.
So is that what we create a policy
which is mutating, you may see a change
there.
Alright. Okay. So it's only add to it.
The mutating admission controller is probably only added
when it's required. Okay. I'll trust you for
now. So let's create our first policy. So
this is just the exact same one that
we kind of had in
the playground
area.
Let's just create this. So we'll call it
deny
default.
I can't type.
What really can't type? I have to look
at the keyboard number from there.
Done.
My computer's
struggling a little bit with me, but we'll
get through it.
So would I this is the
yeah. This I I kinda caught this during
the playground, and I wasn't sure where to
ask a question or not. But this is
a namespaced,
but it's actually
checking the namespace.
So if I apply this to
the jsPolicy namespace,
I mean, in theory, no object should ever
come in where the request namespace is default.
Right?
Like, should this That's correct.
Yep. So how would I make this just
a cluster wide one instead of a namespaced?
No. No. I mean so this essentially means
when you're creating namespaced
resources
regardless of which namespace. So the jsPolicy object
is not namespaced. Right? It's a cluster wide
resource.
Ah, okay. I completely missed that. Right. Gotcha.
That makes more sense. So let's apply it
then. But it doesn't matter where the namespace
is. I should now just be able to
run get JS
policy.
I'm wondering if the Pluto is gonna be
policies like that or like this. There we
go.
Yeah. You can also now run jsPolicyBundle
to actually see, you know, that that inline
JavaScript has been converted to that pep bundle
in the end.
Yeah.
Let me just learn how to type again,
though. There we go. Okay.
When we apply the jsPolicy,
it's being compelled to an artifact, and that's
what we have in the bundle. So if
I run
dash o yaml
on this.
I'm not sure what I did there. Oh,
because
I need that first. Yeah.
And this is the bundle, which is just
base 64 encoded, I guess.
That's correct. Yeah.
I mean, I can't help myself, but take
a look now. So
oh, it's binary encoded.
Well, it's not just the webpack output as,
like, minified JavaScript.
It's actually
stored as a a binary file. Okay.
Cool.
So I guess
to confirm that our policy here is working,
in fact, I'm sure I should just stick
with those guys instead of making this option
there.
So we have applied our policy
and then we can see an action by
trying to create some workload and the default
namespace.
So here, we're just gonna say kubectl create
deployment NGINX
where the image is this.
And our admission controller denies it saying we
are not allowed. Perfect. Exactly what we wanted.
Okay.
So
should we start I mean, do you wanna
dive straight into mutation controllers,
or should I go take a look at
some of the basics on the applied policies?
What interests you both?
Yeah. I think the the the coolest part
is actually
taking a look at the examples.
So if you hit that GitHub button,
that icon on the right upper corner Mhmm.
In the in the project itself,
there is a lot of, you know, example
policies
that really help to to get started with
things.
You can either filter by feature or by
use case.
You can also dive into, you know, more
TypeScript based stuff,
more advanced use cases.
Okay. Let's take a look at
feature
first.
And SSJS
policy features. Is that what that means? That's
right. Yeah. Correct. Yep.
What's your favorite, Rich?
Probably the mutating one.
Alright.
I'm just gonna copy this.
Computer is about twenty seconds behind me, but
I'm sure it's gonna catch up.
There we go. Okay. So
let's see if I can work out what
this does without having to to ask for
help. In fact, I'm I'm gonna delete the
comment before we do it.
So
we have a mutating policy
that looks at the create and update operations
of pods.
It's checking
our annotations.
Okay. So we've got an optional, so there
may not be any annotations and if there's
a required annotation.
Now I'm confused.
Okay. So this isn't alright. Okay. I was
overthinking this. This could be anything. I could
say that I have a requirement that all
pods should have a Rawkode annotation
that says
live.
And if this doesn't exist, this is just
adding that annotation.
Is that correct? Yeah. Right. Okay. Yeah. In
my head, for some weird reason, I was
like, we had some configuration that said all
pods must have this required annotation label that
would add other labels and very
much overcomplicating that for no real rhyme or
reason. So
so now
let's apply this to our cluster first.
And if we try this NGINX deployment again,
but if I just run this in the
jsPolicy namespace,
then what we should see is our nginx
pods all have the Rawkode live annotation,
if I've understood this correctly.
So I'm going to describe
pod
jsPolicy.
And if we scroll up
nice. We mutated that and added our Rawkode
live annotation.
It's nice. It it's it's not difficult.
It's just
it's just JavaScript.
It would have been probably even less difficult
if you hadn't deleted the comment too.
Well, I mean, I've
I'd I'd I just wanted to see if
I could work it out with I know.
I know.
I'm just saying.
Alright. I'll read the comment. I mean, someone's
spent a lot of time and effort to
actually read and write these comments, so it
would be it would be rude of me
just to delete it. So
there's some really important information here that I
can see already on scanner. So we have
the ability to, like, exit early with a
deny or a low statement.
What happens if I met
deny and allow and just let the function
return?
Is there a default action?
No. It's essentially that webhook would not do
anything as part of your, you know, API
server request.
Okay. And then we can call mutate if
we make any modifications.
I mean, the API is is is pretty
simple. Deny, allow, mutate, and off you go.
It's pretty cool. Right. There are a couple
of more functions, actually, special functions. Obviously, you
can use anything built in in JavaScript
and anything
that is possible,
you know, via any kind of, you know,
JavaScript libraries which you're importing.
But if you go back to the to
the other tab with the documentation,
you
can expand
functions down there on the bottom JavaScript reference.
And you see there, there's more functions that
we added,
you know, essentially for ease of use. I
think one of my favorites is actually lists
and get.
That is essentially to receive resources out of
the Kubernetes cluster.
So let's say you wanna have a policy
that
makes sure your ingress host names are unique.
Right?
You can't just look at the current object
coming in. You actually need to take a
look at all the ingresses in your cluster.
Right?
And you essentially need to retrieve those resources
somehow. You can do that with list, for
example.
Ah, very cool.
So I have, like
I I give this very opinionated view of
of what get ops means to me and
my own production infrastructure.
And, like, one of the things I try
to emit from all of my repositories is
domain information.
Like, this is rockode.com
or this is staging.rockode.com.
I'm actually trying to rely on the
component that provisions the cluster to inject a
config map that has, oh, this is what
your domain is for this cluster. Mhmm. I
could now use JS policy with a mutating
policy that says go fetch this config map,
pull out the value for the domain, and
inject that into all of the ingresses as
I apply them to the cluster
and just simplify my entire setup there.
That is awesome. I love it when I
click through episodes like this, and I have
a real use case for the thing myself
that I can go and just deploy No
way. Them.
It happened the last time you came up
with use cases that we hadn't thought of.
So it's it's really fun to to get
you to take a look at these things
because you definitely always have, like, some new
takes that that we hadn't even
considered.
Yeah. I I I just like to do
weird stuff with technology. But this I I'm
really excited about this. Like, I can I
can already see this fixing my GitOps? Because
I I just don't like putting that information
in the repository, and I'm not a big
fan of my GitOps tooling right back to
the repository with this information.
And this solves a lot of these problems
because it's much more dynamic
than I've had access to through things like
Kiverrno and and Open in the past. So
it just opens up a whole bunch of
these I I don't wanna say, like, power
user things, but, you know, people that are
going slightly off the beaten track and just
wanna do more exploratory experimental stuff,
having the ability to do those on the
fly lookups,
it's almost a superpower. And I think I
said that with v cluster too. So user
user winning me over with your technology.
I think I think there's
there's an important
thing in terms of being opinionated with tools.
Like, a lot of users, I think, especially
newer folks,
want you to be opinionated. They want you
to, you know, have a an example architecture
or, you know, to to be able to
tell them really in basic terms how to
use the tool, but you're always gonna have
those folks who have different use cases, right,
and different needs
that, like, the the basic kind of opinionated
workflow won't address. And and so the tools
also have to be flexible enough for people
to be able to do the things that
they need to do.
Yeah. Well said.
Okay.
Maybe we could cover a couple more of
these functions,
and then we'll jump back to that examples
and take a look at a couple more
of the features.
So I see read files saying, and, immediately,
I'm thinking this can read a file from
somewhere.
Yeah, so this is pulling in secret information
from the secrets directory.
Oh, that's what And fetching, so I can
actually pull remote URLs from like guests or
online,
etcetera, and just pull them into account.
I guess that's the cool thing about having
access to the JavaScript stuff.
What else do we see? What's re queue?
Let's see.
That's That's a good question. I think that's
for controller policies.
Yeah. This one has a big comment. That
should be a warning saying for me that
just just move on. Go look at something
else. Come back to this one. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. This is for controller policies. You see
that on the bottom, right, in line 30?
Yeah.
The controller policies are a little bit different
because, essentially, they're not happening as part of
your kubectl
request. Right?
They happen afterwards based on events, and they're
queued. Right?
So, essentially, event comes in, and then you
have these policies which which I'll put in
a queue and execute it,
I think, you know, first in,
first out.
And then you can essentially add the the
request to the queue again.
You know, there may be certain use cases
where you wanna reevaluate an event later on
again.
Okay. Cool.
Let's pick one more just because I think
it fits in with some of the stuff
we've already looked at. So I see a
warn here. We've seen deny. We've seen allow
I guess, one allows it, but logs somewhere
that, hey. You may wanna look at this
in due course. Is that correct?
Yes. That's that's exactly it.
Nice. Intuitive,
which is good. Alright. Let's pick it up.
In, you know, a a situation you might
wanna
use that in is, you know, something you're
gonna deprecate down the road, you know, and
you wanna start letting the developers know that,
you know, they can't they can't depend on
that thing being there anymore.
Yeah. 100%.
And something we see, like sorry. Need to
look at this. You also show it in
in kubectl.
Right? So the developer is in the end,
you know, able to see that output as
well,
which is pretty powerful. I think kubectl itself
does it as well with, like, the deprecated
ingress, you know, better
resources, etcetera. They they did that for a
couple of versions before actually
killing
that API group off, which makes a lot
of sense because other otherwise, you know, not
everybody reads the chains logs every time they
come out and makes sense their page is
long. Right?
Yeah. Definitely. I mean, one of the things
I think it fits in really well with
with this kind of tooling is that we've
seen pod security policies being deprecated recently.
And the answer to that is to rely
on tools like OPA and Caverno, and I'm
assuming JS policy.
Is that something that's available to people? Like,
do you ship a bundle that is the
basic pod security policies for people to take
advantage of, or is that something that they
would just write their own policies for to
enforce the bets that they want?
I'm actually not sure if we have an
example in there, but we we may.
I know that we have something about escalating
privileges
of bots, but I don't know exactly if
we have pod security policy.
We do have denied privilege escalation. So maybe
that's a good one to take a look
at.
And we also have a
couple of oh, we've got one question and
no mocking me in the chat.
There we go. Hi, Noah.
So I use my clustered automation for all
these clusters just because it's it's so well
written now.
But, yeah, the ambassador ingress controller is currently
broken since I upgraded the clusters to one
twenty two because of a deprecation,
and and I'm not getting warnings about that.
So
yeah. Very funny at all. Thank you for
watching.
Russell
has got a question.
So
what are the scopes?
The namespace filtering looks to be done by
the JavaScript. So it seems like namespace scope
isn't required.
Does the scope alter the shape of request
object?
I think that's the same assumption I made
that Lucas kinda tackled earlier, but
do you wanna add anything to that?
Yeah. I mean, essentially, you can specify within
the policy really the scope of that policy.
Right? Whether that whether you're restricted to a
certain group or you're to
an API server version or resource, in this
case, pods. Right?
And then a certain operation,
you can,
you know, restrict it to a certain namespace.
And, essentially, we we won't even receive that
request, right, when
when you don't specify that. So there's really,
like, no overhead for any other resources. It's
only those resource that you actually specify that
will be validated by the particular policy.
So that is pretty extensive filtering capabilities.
Yeah. So, yeah, you don't have the thing
firing off, you know, when people are
altering other other kinds of resources.
Yeah. And I think I'll just
highlight something that Luca said earlier just so
it's not missed. But all GS policies are
cluster wide. Right?
I took a note of that in my
head, so yeah. Okay. Yeah. So all the
policies policy object itself is cluster wide. Right?
Yeah. Exactly. Got it.
Okay. So we pulled up the privilege escalation
one. So this is an example of one
of the pod security policies that kind of
disappears.
And there's a little bit of syntax in
here that's
that's just JavaScript, isn't it? So this is
I'm gonna try and explain JavaScript, and I'm
gonna feel measurably. Feel free to correct me
here. Right? So
we're just seeing that we want to take
a look at all the containers
and the pod.
I love that it defaults to empty. I
mean, can you apply a pod with no
containers? I'm not sure.
The any containers definitely could be defaulted to
empty.
And then this is the spread operator in
JavaScript. So essentially what we're saying is get
all the containers and all the other containers,
and then we're using the for each iterator
where we're just checking to see if the
security context is set in any of them.
And then you just got a deny message
here that says that's not allowed.
Like
yeah.
I love that I can read this. I've
gotta say it's pretty nice.
Okay. A question from
Frank.
Is it possible to validate existing
objects or resources, I guess, and get some
phase of report out of them?
Yeah. I mean, you can you can actually
take a look at, you know, what you've
already denied
in your example
by, you know, getting the resource JS policy
violations,
which should give you an insight of, you
know, what has been violated.
Okay. So that's a that's a new custom
resource?
Exactly. Yeah. That's more for the reporting purpose.
Vial
there we go.
Well, let's take a look at this in
YAML. I mean, I'm assuming I can maybe
describe it too.
Too early.
Okay.
Oh, there we go. So we got a
violation here. So this is gripped by the
policy itself, and then
the status is just a list of violations
that is denied.
And we've got a timestamp, the object that
was denied,
and then the message.
So I think what Frank is saying is,
like, say, I've got my production infrastructure already
up and running,
and then I think, okay. I've watched the
Rawkode live episodes and jsPolicy is like the
bee's knees, so I'm gonna go and deploy
it to all of my clusters now.
It's not gonna work on any of the
resources within the cluster until
we do a new update or apply or
something like that, or is there a way
to retrospectively
scan existing resources?
No. That does not exist at this point.
But I I think none of the policy
engines do that right now. I mean, essentially,
everybody's just hooking into the regular admission control
web
Yeah. You know, webhooks and, you know, they're
not being fired on existing objects and set
unless you, you know, reapply them. But, I
mean, some some objects may
I mean, even if you were to just
add an annotation to all objects, like a
random annotation, you set it to true and
then you remove it again.
You may have policies which only listen to
create
because they forbid create actions. So there's
no way to essentially capture everything, I think.
Yeah. Although, I guess this is where your
controller policies could come in. I mean, you
could probably write something as a controller policy
that did
that looked for violations and triggered updates via
annotations or labels or something silly like that
just to force them to go through the
loop. But that
that's the segue. We don't need to go
into that right now.
But, Frank, there are violation reports that are
available here. I'm assuming you could write tooling
to pull those out and store them in
Prometheus or InfluxDB or anything like that to
get access to them.
Frank is actually the author of the kivernal
policy reporter,
So I'm gonna ask him Oh, nice. Okay.
Gonna ask him now to add support for
this so that we can take advantage of
all that great tooling as well.
Okay. Let's
jump back to our examples.
So Let's see if we can pick maybe
just one more feature and then we can
see what we wanna do after that.
So either
of you have anything that you want to
show off before I pick one randomly.
I think dependencies may be interesting to see.
Does this mean it's gonna give something from
NPM?
Yeah. Exactly. Alright. Okay. Cool.
Oh, you're pulling on low dash. I was
expecting left pad. You've let me down.
But
well, let's see. We got a
create operation on pods. Only now we have
access to a dependencies key on the spec
where we can just list any NPM dependency.
And then in the JavaScript, we're just using
Lodash to do
comparisons.
It's pretty neat the way that works. I'm
assuming then that when the JS policy is
ingested,
that the Webpack step is just pulling all
those in and spinning out the bundle just
like all the other policies.
Yep.
Yeah. That's correct. That's essentially why we separate
a JS policy from JS policy bundle.
And, again, like, typically
so this is actually a little ugly. Right?
Because you're writing JavaScript within YAML. Right?
So the benefits I was mentioning earlier regarding
tooling don't apply to this because, like, your
IDE will not, you know, show code highlighting,
fix your imports,
you know, and your package JSON cannot be
scanned by dependency
vulnerabilities
and things like that.
So
the actual best approach is to create these
bundles yourself
and essentially just have a JavaScript object, a
package JSON,
and essentially create these bundles and then create
the JS policy without dependencies and without JavaScript
here. But if you just wanna test something
on the on the fly,
essentially, this dependencies
section allows you to do the same as
the dependencies section in your package JSON.
Okay. So I'm trying to think how this
would work, and, like, I I get up.
So so it's that I would have
my own repository with just, like, NPM in
it that creates a JavaScript project. I start
to write all of my policies as JavaScript,
probably each one being its own module.
And then I would configure my webpack to
just
compare each of those down.
And then I guess I you would just
use CICD to then
genetically generate the YAML and apply them. I'm
not do do we have an example of
what that would look like?
Yeah. If you go if you go to
the docs,
there's actually a project
that is set up for TypeScript, but you
could just write JavaScript in it as well.
Mhmm. You see that there are JS policy
SDK,
like, policies. Yeah. Exactly.
And you can find that project on GitHub,
and it's essentially a starter project. Right? You
can check that out.
And, essentially,
it it has the, you know, webpack and
everything configured
so that you can directly, you know, get
started, write your policies with them.
I've gotta say, I have tried writing a
webpack config in the past and failed every
single time. So I'm glad it exists.
So let's see what this looks like then.
Okay. So we got policies
and then
annotations apply. Okay. Let's take a look at
the namespace one.
Okay. So you just provide, like, the scale
and oh, I was just betting that to
be a
a bundle?
No. This is actually just the the policy
because the the bundle is created by webpack,
right, from
your source code that is in this index
TypeScript file. Right?
And the YAML code is essentially just
defining the JS policy, like, you know, the
scope of the policy. Right? Which objects
is it mutating? Is it validating?
Things like that. And then the pop the
bundle is created on demand.
Okay. Got it.
Does
this show me how it's applied to the
cluster?
Yeah. If you scroll down in the read
me, it it shows you the NPM commands.
Right? So, essentially, you have the NPM run
compile,
which is doing the compile step, and the
output of that compile step is essentially
you're gonna see a policies folder. So right
now, you just have a source folder and
a test folder. It's
gonna create a policies folder, which is on
gitignore because there's no reason to version these.
You know? I mean, you saw that earlier.
Right? They're
base 64
encoded,
and
they're also g g zips, essentially.
So that's why you saw, like, you know,
the binary kind of output earlier.
You we would actually have to unzip it
as well.
So there's no reason to version that in
Git because it's essentially just your source code.
And you can run that compile command, and
it would create that policies folder. And that
policies folder would contain
the policy YAML and the policy
bundle YAML
for each one of the policies that has
a folder in this, you know, source folder.
Okay. So, yeah, you can see all the
different scripts configured on the the package dot
JSON there. So of the standard compile, the
webpack bundling, and then there's the apply step
here too. So
okay. That makes a lot more sense. Is
actually pretty cool.
It's so we have this compile watch, which,
you know, whenever you change the source code
or the policy YAML, it would automatically, you
know, kind of do the note one watching
step.
But you can also run the watch reply,
which would not only create the YAMLs, but
also run essentially kubectl
apply, right, which is pretty smooth if you're,
you know, working in test cluster. You don't
even have to manually do the kubectl apply
when you're writing your policies.
Okay. Got it. And you're just doing that
through a webpack plugin. Right? The the writing
the YAML, the policy YAML? Is that right?
Is that what this is? Yeah. Correct. Okay.
Yes. Exactly.
Okay. And in the end, you know, that
policy
that JS policy code, you know, if you
really wanna do, like, GitOps, etcetera, that is
also something you could, you know, check-in in
your repository,
that, you know, policies folder.
But, again, like, it's it's not a requirement.
You could essentially
also have a CICD pipeline, which essentially does
that NPM compiled step and then runs kubectl
apply.
It's pretty much the same thing.
Yeah. I think some of them are seeing
now with, like, Argo and Flux is that
they're really providing the ability to run custom
commands on these repositories as well. So, I
mean, we're almost at a stage where I
could just hook this repository up to Argo
or Flux and just say, here, go run
an NPM
up up compile apply, and that would just
that would just do it. So
okay. Very cool.
Is there a if I click on the
test directory, is it gonna have a test,
or is it gonna be empty?
Oh, sure. Has, one sample test.
That's one sample test.
Nice.
So, yeah, we can
it's always nice to see an example of
tests.
I like testing, so I've been able to
see how to do that. Yeah. I'm definitely
gonna be forking this repository and stealing it
from my ingress objection thing. So very nice.
Yeah. It's also kinda nice. You can see
here that we're actually importing on the top
the official, like, Kubernetes client node. Right? And
we're creating pod objects down there. And because
it's TypeScript,
everything is typed,
which is pretty neat. So we're essentially creating
v one spec, you know, for the pod
and things like that. And it's essentially,
you know, a a lot more reliable than
having
only end to end tests where you apply
YAML to your cluster and see if the
policy actually works. You You can actually run
very fine granular tests on pretty much each
function
that you're writing in JavaScript.
Awesome.
Okay. We got I expect
there will be some folks who don't get
this deep, you know, who will just use
it and do,
you know, things more like what you see
in the examples. And and that's totally fine,
but, you know, there is this, you know,
extra power to to use all of the
the tools that come in that JavaScript ecosystem
if you if you wanna get that deep.
Yeah. Definitely.
We've got a question also Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't go Oh, sorry. Go ahead.
I was just gonna say we have a
a question from Jack in the chat, which
I think I can even answer. But he
said, why import whole of Lodash here? I
mean, the answer is because you can. Right?
That's
why we would do it.
Yeah. I mean, in the end, I think
Webpack is gonna strip a lot away
that may not be needed even.
I I I'm not a Webpack expert, so
I don't know how it works, but I
think they're doing a lot of optimizations in
there. It does a lot of tree shaking
and modification and a whole bunch of other
fancy stuff that I've seen the compiler talks
from conferences,
but I had never paid enough attention to
understand it. Yeah. I believe you're right.
Okay.
I think one thing I wanted to point
out is sharing functions as well. If you
go to the policies folder again Mhmm. To
the to the source folder, sorry, with that
contains these policies,
you see this lip folder as well, right,
on the one level higher.
And that's essentially where you could, you know,
define functions that would be used by several
of your policies.
So, typically, your policies
are grouped by resources.
Right?
So you have certain policies which apply to
deployments.
You may have other ones which apply to
pods. Right? They have a totally different spec,
but you may wanna check similar things. You
may wanna prevent,
you know, privilege escalation, for example, and that's
part of the pod spec. But you also
wanna check it for deployments and stateful sets.
And in Lib, you'll find a function
which essentially can be shared and called from
both of these policies, essentially.
Where's the end containers or metadata?
Yeah. I think if you go to containers
and then validate capabilities,
for example, is one of them, or validate
images is another one. Right?
We're essentially running something here on the pod
spec, and this function expects the pod pod
spec as an input. Right? Alright. Okay. And
if you're now going to the policies
again,
so to your source to the source folder
and then policies,
and then you'll see deployments and parts. It's
two different right? We're validating them differently because
we may run different checks on them. Right?
Like, deployments might have, like, eight other functions
that need to be checked. Right?
They may have different annotations, etcetera, but both
of them wanna do that cap capabilities check.
And then we can essentially if you go
into validate ports, for example,
and then in the actual TypeScript code,
you'll see that we're running this validate container
capabilities,
and we're passing the pods back to it.
Right?
It's pretty straightforward.
Yeah. I like that. Being able to extract
all the common functionality into
shareable libraries to avoid duplicating code everywhere that
you go. And just having simple functions like
validate namespace and validate container images. Yeah, that
makes a lot of sense.
Very nice. I like that.
Alright. Is there anything
else from an example of repository you would
like to show our audience before we finish
up for today?
I think that was a lot of content
already.
No. That that that's alright. We have we
have covered a lot.
A lot for hold on. Let me pop
it back over to
there we go. Yeah. There there there is
a lot here. I mean, I think
just exploring the capabilities from the validating and
mutating aspect and be able to bring that
into my cluster
and to be able to enforce the policies
that I need and make the changes that
I need is a great way just to
get started and kick the tires on this
and build out that tooling. I really,
you know, need to explore how to apply
this to my cluster and get it started,
and I'm very excited to do that.
And we never really touched a lot on
the controller stuff, but there's just a whole
bunch of different capabilities there that I could
just have a field day with playing with.
I think there's, you know, potentially at least
a couple of different types of users of
this. Right? Like, one is the people
like you who, you know, are very familiar
with JavaScript and TypeScript and and wanna get
deep and and do those things. But I
think, you know, another set is the folks
that were the reason that this got built,
which are the people who
have tried to use some of the other
tools and, you know, had difficulty for some
reason and are looking for something where the
policies are are easier to read. And,
you know, the thing that I wanna emphasize
is that
you should be doing admission control, whichever of
these tools that you use. Right? Yeah. Like,
if you're not doing it at all and
you're not doing it because
you tried and it was hard,
I really recommend taking a look at at
jsPolicy.
Yeah. You're 100% right. Like, people need to
be adding policies to their cluster,
especially with policy could be policies being deprecated.
There's a whole bunch of malicious things there
that just need to be stamped out, and
jsPolicy
is a nice way of doing that. I
really like that capability of working with Versus
Code, getting syntax highlight, and, you know, even
using Copilot.
I wonder how many of my policies I
could probably write if I just let it
try and do it for me.
That's really funny. Sorry.
How'd you go?
No. I I was just gonna say I
I hadn't even thought about that. I I
don't have access to Copilot yet, so I
haven't I haven't I've gotta be honest. I'm
so amazed by it. And I know there's
a there's a whole bunch of ethical debates
right now about whether we should be using
it and such, but I have found that
it reads my mind. Like, I can just
write, I want to
start something with this, and then it goes,
oh, you're trying to do this thing. And
I'm like, yeah. I am trying to do
that thing.
So maybe
in time, as more people adopt JS policy
and are writing their policies, we'll find that
a lot of that Copilot magic is gonna
work there.
And pod security policies be I can see
that being distributed as an NPM package, and
I'm leading on top of that more and
more
best practices that are really hard to find
in the Kubernetes ecosystems. And I think with
JS policy, Loft are now in a really
unique position to be able to distribute that
in a very consumable way that we haven't
really seen before. Very exciting stuff.
Any final words before I let you both
get back to your day?
Just thank you so much for for another
invitation. That that that's really great that we,
you know,
are talking about a second project just, like,
I think, like, a month later or so
or two months later.
It was a lot of fun talking about
vCluster,
and it looks like jsPolicy
went smooth regarding the demo as well. Like
to see that I was since you mentioned
at the beginning, I was kind of afraid,
you know, is this gonna break something?
But it didn't This one this one is
a little different because vCluster is something that
had been part of our commercial prod product
before we open sourced it. Right? And so
people have been kicking the tires on that
for for quite a while, but but jsPolicy
is is quite a bit newer.
But it it's always fun to to see
your take on these rules, David. Like, you
know, you always come up with some things
that I hadn't even thought of, and so
it's it's a real pleasure to get to
come on here.
Well, yeah. Thank you.
It's just really
I'm I'm really happy with what I've seen
so far. And like I said, I've already
got a direct use case that I'm gonna
have to go and kick a tires with
us this week. So, you know, I'll be
sure to to share my successes or failures
but I'm pretty confident based on what I've
seen today that it's it's gonna be wonderful
for for what I need.
Unfortunately for you too know how it goes.
Unfortunately for you too, that you've now come
on and demoed two projects that I really,
really like. So, like, the third one's gonna
have to be phenomenal. I don't know why
you've got cooking in the kitchen, but it's
gonna have to be good.
So no pressure. I think we I think
we've maybe taken a break from launching new
open source tools for a little bit. We
we'll see. Would yeah. Because you're already tackling
difficult problems like policy and multitenant. Like, anytime
I now have a difficult problem, I'm just
gonna have to be like, hey. Here's the
thing. Please go run with it. So we'll
see.
Alright. Thank you both again. It was an
absolute pleasure to work through this. A very
exciting tool. I encourage everyone who's watched and
followed along to go check it out and
simplify your policy management on Kubernetes.
I hope you both have a wonderful day.
I'll let you go now, and I'll hopefully
speak to you again soon. Have a good
one. Bye. Thanks, Steven.
Bye.